[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
question d'actualité sur LCP très
heureuse de vous retrouver ici Salle des
pas perdue à quelques mètres de la salle
des quatre colonnes et de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale où se tiendront
tout à l'heure les questions au
Gouvernement une séance que vous pourrez
suivre à partir de 15 heures en direct
et en intégralité sur LCP alors c'est
l'heure du bilan ici à l'Assemblée il y
a un an quasiment jour pour jour on
découvrait le visage de ce nouvel
hémicycle avec une majorité relative une
première depuis 30 ans deux pôles
extrêmes renforcés des parties
traditionnelles affaiblies on disait
l'assemblée un gouvernable alors qu'en
est-il 12 mois plus tard on fait le
point dans cette émission avec nos
invités en plateau et puis nos reporters
sur place nous retrouverons Stéphanie
Despierre et Marion Becker qui se trouve
salle des quatre colonnes nous
retrouvons également Valérie Brochard
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale pour le menu des questions au
gouvernement et puis nous vous ferons
vivre à partir de 14h45 14h50 l'arrivée
de la première ministre et des membres
du gouvernement ce sera par l'entrée
principale du palais Bourbon
c'est-à-dire la cour d'honneur alors on
retrouve tout de suite Stéphanie
Despierres salle des quatre colonnes
quelle est l'ambiance Stéphanie un an
après ces élections alors vous le voyez
pour le moment la salle des quatre
colonnes est encore calme mais ce matin
il y avait beaucoup de journalistes et
puis les députés de tous les groupes
politiques ont tiré le bilan de cette
première année alors la majorité
Renaissance avec ses alliés horizons et
modem on fait une conférence de presse
pour dire regardez l'assemblée
fonctionne elle n'est pas bloquée
contrairement à ce que les commentateurs
annonçaient au moment des législatives
des résultats l'année dernière et puis
la nupesse également notamment les
insoumis on fait une conférence de
presse bilan alors eux ils ont carrément
édité 72 pages pour vanter thème par
thème leur travail ici à l'Assemblée et
pour fustiger du style Une macronie et
un rassemblement national main dans la
main contre les travailleurs c'est leur
ligne argumentaire pour ce bilan à
donnant l'Assemblée nationale et puis
Marine Le Pen le rassemblement national
a choisi plus sobre à choisi de faire
une adresse aux Français qu'elle a
publié
sur Twitter hier ou elle explique elle
fait le bilan des c'est un an à
l'Assemblée nationale avec 89 députés de
son parti on va retrouver à présent
Valérie Brochard dans les tribunes de
l'hémicycle Valérie de quoi va-t-on
parler cet après-midi lors de la séance
de questions au gouvernement
et bien Brigitte pour cette nouvelle
séance de questions au gouvernement
c'est le projet de tunnel ferroviaire
entre Lyon et Turin qui préoccupe les
élus une manifestation pourtant
interdite par la préfecture de Savoie
toutefois eu lieu le week-end dernier
les députés souhaitent revenir sur cet
événement mais également sur le projet
en lui-même
merci Valérie en vous retrouvera un
petit peu plus tard dans cette émission
pour d'autres questions au Gouvernement
j'accueille sur ce plateau Prisca
théveno bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes député
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine et
porte-parole du groupe Renaissance
Aurélie trouvait bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis alors je vous le
disais le 19 juin dernier c'est un
véritable coup de théâtre qui a eu lieu
ici à l'Assemblée nationale des
élections législatives pour la première
fois depuis 30 ans la majorité n'est que
relative 300 nouveaux députés sont élus
parmi eux beaucoup du rassemblement
national devenu premier groupe
d'opposition de nombreux insoumis
quelques jours plus tard il faisait leur
entrée vous le voyez sur ces images à
l'Assemblée nous les avons suivies dans
leur premier pas à la découverte du
Palais Bourbon
une réaction vous vous attendiez à ça à
cette première année comme ça ici à
l'Assemblée c'est vrai effectivement il
y a un an presque jour pour jour ici
dans ces mêmes locaux on nous prédisait
l'impossible l'impossible action
politique dans le cadre d'une majorité
relative et force est de constater c'est
que aujourd'hui on peut faire le bilan
le bilan c'est 33 33 textes votés
adopter définitivement et dans ces 33
textes il y en a une vingtaine qui sont
des propositions de loi proposition de
loi ça veut dire qu'elles émanent
directement du Parlement et de la
liberté parlementaire de chacun on va y
revenir bien sûr mais pour vous ça a été
quand même une surprise de découvrir
cette assemblée telle que vous l'avez
vécu ces 12 derniers mois alors il y a
eu peut-être une surprise peut-être mais
il y a surtout eu un choc celui du 4 des
89 89 qui sont aujourd'hui de 88 mais 89
députés du rassemblement national qui
sont rentrés effectivement comme un
groupe de force au sein de l'hémicycle
mais la plus grande si vous voulez des
surprises ou niveau des faits c'est que
on nous a beaucoup parlé de au cours de
cette dernière année de la majorité
relative mais en réalité il y a une
majorité d'actions celle qui agit texte
par texte sujet par sujet avec des
débats souvent très houleux mais qui
finit par aboutir sur des actions
concrètes pour porter nos auditions mais
également répondre aux problématiques du
quotidien il faut le préciser parce que
vous êtes toutes les deux de nouvelles
députés élus pour la première fois en
2022 Aurélie trouvait juste retour sur
cette année comment vous la qu'est-ce
que vous avez vécu vous c'est ces
derniers mois en fait à mes
particulières déjà parce que moi je
viens pas de la politique j'étais
responsable associative et enseignante
chercheuse par ailleurs comme beaucoup
d'ailleurs dans le groupe France
insoumise nupet nous venons voilà pas du
monde politique beaucoup du monde
associatif et de et de multiples métiers
donc j'ai découvert aussi par la même la
politique si vous voulez mais j'avoue
que quand j'étais élue député de la
nation nous sommes arrivés à 151 députés
de la nupaisse première force
d'opposition dans cette article
évidemment nous sommes dit je me suis
dit ah mais nous allons pouvoir au moins
tenter d'infléchir la politique de ce
gouvernement la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron et le bilan c'est qu'au bout d'un
an en fait nos marges de manoeuvre les
droits de l'opposition et bien nous
avons l'impression qu'ils ont été
grignotés petit à petit et finalement
que nous ne pouvons pas exercer ce
pourquoi nous avons été élus
c'est-à-dire voter les lois essentielles
puisque nous n'avons pas pu voter une
fine le budget qui est quand même
l'essentiel
des retraites en émis sur les retraites
en hémicycle voilà donc ça c'est aussi
je dirais quelque chose pour lequel
évidemment nous sommes en colère ou
déçus mais en même temps nous gardons
toute notre détermination pour
construire une alternative à cela la
détermination mais est-ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'un an plus tard en tout
cas la fraîcheur des débuts a laissé la
place à l'affrontement politique les
débats ont été nourris dans l'hémicycle
les invectives fréquentes le
gouvernement a dû user à 11 reprises du
49-3 et les oppositions ont répliqué par
cette motion de censure alors ce matin
les trois groupes de la majorité étaient
réunis autour de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne ils se sont félicités
d'avoir malgré tout pu avancer on écoute
la présidente du groupe Renaissance
Aurore berger nous avons fait je crois
la démonstration à la fois de l'unité de
la majorité présidentielle qui a
largement pu être mesurée et éprouvé
dans les moments qui étaient des vrais
moments de tests et aussi difficile
éprouvant surtout la démonstration a pu
être faite que texte à prétexte hors-tex
budgétaire nous avons su à chaque fois
trouver une majorité nouvelle donc nous
avons su nous fondre aussi dans cette
nouvelle donne politique avec cette
majorité dites relative Stéphanie
Despierre on vous retrouve celle des
quatre colonnes on disait effectivement
cette assemblée un gouvernable avec une
majorité relative force et de constater
qu'au bout de 12 mois un certain nombre
de textes a été adopté oui Brigitte
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas du tout
bloquée à chaque texte le gouvernement
doit tricoter une majorité et il y
parvient même si c'est parfois dans la
douleur en un an 68 lois ont été votées
par les députés sur le pouvoir d'achat
le nucléaire les énergies renouvelables
sur la sécurité ou encore l'assurance
chômage et bien Élisabeth borne a réussi
à faire passer ses projets de loi
parfois grâce au soutien des
républicains parfois à celui à des
socialistes alors elle navigue un peu à
vue mais pour l'instant ça marche il y a
eu quand même beaucoup de motion de
censure aussi Stéphanie oui 17 motions
de censure en un an dont 13 de par les
insoumis et ses alliés c'est un record
ce sont d'émotions qui répondaient pour
la plupart à l'utilisation du 49-3 par
l'exécutif Elizabeth borne la dégainée
11 fois là aussi un record notamment à
l'automne pour faire adopter le budget
et bien évidemment en mars lors de la
très controversée réforme des retraites
alors toute l'émotion ont échoué à faire
tomber le gouvernement mais fin mars
Elisabeth borne a vraiment eu chaud elle
a sauvé son poste de justesse à neuf
voix près
un mot peut-être pour qualifier cette
année à l'Assemblée quel serait-il
vitalité vitalité vitalité parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est peut-être passé un
peu d'une tranquillité parlementaire à
une vitalité républicaine et à cette
vitalité républicaine par contre
attention elle ne doit pas se résoudre
ou se résumer à des coups de force des
coûts de pression des polémiques qui
viendraient remplacer la politique mais
bien de passer peut-être à une politique
moins de bras de fer mais plus de mains
tendues et c'est grâce à cette politique
de main tendue que nous avons réussi
effectivement à avancé bien évidemment
et je le dis de façon très tranquille
c'est pas toujours évident nous avons
d'ailleurs hier fini en commission à
plus de minuit et demi à valider un
texte celui du texte sur le partage de
la valeur créée mais nous continuerons
nous continuerons à considérer que nous
devons prendre en considération la
mission première qui nous a été confiée
par les Françaises et les Français il y
a un an celles de faire avec la
pluralité politique qui existe dans
d'autres pays et cette pluralité elle
doit être une rich pas un point bloquant
Aurélie trouvée pour vous s'il fallait
un mot justement pour qualifier cette
année à l'Assemblée je l'ai dit dans une
tribune pour le journal de l'Huma la
violence la violence d'abord parce que
c'est la violence de la politique
sociale de ce gouvernement une violence
aussi quand on voit le contraste je suis
député en Seine-Saint-Denis le contraste
entre ce que peuvent témoigner les gens
dans ma circo dans ma circonscription je
gagne 600 euros de retraite j'aime faire
expulser de mon logement alors que une
loi une loi est votée ici pour justement
faire en sorte que il y ait plus
d'expulsion des logements par exemple ça
c'est de la violence et je dirais aussi
ce que j'appelle la violence du calme la
violence du calme c'est aussi le fait
qu'on nous intime de nous taire on nous
intime aussi de ne pas faire ce pourquoi
on a été lu je l'ai dit ne pas voter les
lois essentielles ne pas même pouvoir
dans nos niches parlementaires pouvoir
nous en tant qu'opposition menée à bien
un examen de projet de loi
je pense à celui sur sur leur traite ça
aussi pour nous c'est de la violence et
donc voilà je et en même temps j'ai
envie de dire face à cette violence moi
la protection celle que je trouve c'est
celle que je trouve en circonscription
c'est à dire c'est solidarités locales
par exemple tous ces bénévoles du
Secours populaire que je rencontre et
qui font ce que le l'État devrait faire
c'est à dire assurer les besoins de base
des gens aujourd'hui il y a quand même
16% des gens une personne sur 8 qui
déclare qu'elle a faim c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus qu'il y a un an avec
un gouvernement qui ne fait rien contre
ça donc évidemment en même temps nous
sommes en colère nous sommes aussi votre
initiative parlementaire qui peut
changer les choses voilà donc voilà
agir mais nous nous continuerons à nous
battre en tant qu'opposition même si
évidemment ces droits de l'opposition
sont petit à petit grignotées risquez
vous entendez c'est la violence qui
revient qui est le mot que qui
qualifierait cette année pour pour
Aurélie trouver alors c'est vrai vous
avez légiféré mais mais à quel prix 11
11 49-3 c'est pas le record de Michel
rocker et c'est 13,49 ans mais on est
quand même pas loin de la fourchette
très très haute attention je pense qu'il
faut faire attention j'aimerais juste
rappeler que nous sommes dans une
démocratie parlementaire et qui
effectivement elle est régie par des
règles ces règles qui sont connues et
sud de tous et donc oui nous pouvons
utiliser ces règles dans le cadre de
l'exercice de mono mandat mais attention
à ne pas en faire un trait d'union sur
une éventuelle violence la seule
violence qui existerait serait de
considérer que nous pouvons tout faire
tout dire et en fait finalement que
notre travail ne servirait à rien oui il
y a eu des 49,3 utilisés est-ce qu'on
aurait préféré faire autrement bien
évidemment mais force est de constater
que dans beaucoup d'endroits sur
beaucoup de sujets notamment sur le
sujet de la réforme des retraites ou sur
le sujet des textes budgétaires il n'y a
pas eu le droit à des débats les débats
ont été empêchés et je le dis de manière
assez étonnée ils n'ont pas été empêché
directement par les parlementaires
eux-mêmes mais ils ont été empêchés sur
le coup de tweet de la part d'un homme
et je suis désolé de le dire d'un homme
qui ne si même plus aujourd'hui vous
parler de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour ne pas lever les amendements sur la
réforme des retraits il avait dit il
avait twitté l'avait revendiqué et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
peut-être aussi pouvoir en capacité
regarder devant nous et nous dire
qu'effectivement nous opposer c'est
important mais nous opposer pour servir
des ego ça ne sert à rien nous opposer
pour servir des idéaux ça permet
d'avance de faire avancer le débat et
nous avons pu le faire souvenez-vous
alors ça fait pas le buzz médiatique
mais ça fait l'action politique en début
d'année nous avons voté un texte qui
venait d'une sénatrice
udi c'est un texte sur les violences
conjugales pour aider les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales avoir
une aide financière ce texte a été
effectivement est arrivé ici à
l'Assemblée et nous avons porté des
amendements communs ELV pslr modem
horizon Renaissance nous l'avons fait
nous pouvons le faire et nous devons
continuer à le faire donc je le dis très
sincère très sincèrement aujourd'hui je
ne chercherai pas à me chicailler en ce
jour j'ai plutôt une lueur d'espoir pour
dire que les débats sont âpres ils sont
houleux ils sont denses si et seulement
si ils arrivent à nourrir l'action
politique alors on parle de violence
verbale à votre égard à l'égard de la
France insoumise de la nuque mais plutôt
de la France insoumise sur la façon de
légiférer pendant ces années Gérald
Darmanin a parlé même de bordélisation
ici dans l'enceinte de l'émission
comment vous acceptez ces mots est-ce
que vous assumez finalement
de bousculer un petit peu les habitudes
ici dans l'hémicycle vous voyez bien que
le problème c'est que on pointe du doigt
le chat a eu alors qu'en fait ça a été
dit c'est la vivacité des débats ça
c'est une chose que nous ne soyons pas
d'accord tant mieux et je dois rappeler
que dans beaucoup d'autres Parlement par
exemple au Royaume-Uni et bien les
débats sont encore beaucoup plus houeux
et heureusement nous n'avons pas comme
le mandat précédent des députés qui
quasiment tous votent la même chose à
part quelques quelques députés de
l'opposition donc nous avons une réelle
opposition 151 députés de la nupesse le
problème il est comment ce gouvernement
gouverne voilà parce qu'on dit c'est
gouvernable oui mais comment il gouverne
est-ce qu'il prend en compte est-ce
qu'il infléchit sa politique en fonction
de ce que lui propose de ce que de ce
que construit aussi l'opposition et ben
ma réponse est NON
je peux vous donner l'exemple de la
réforme des mais quand même sans moi
quelle est le seul élément il y avait
pris plus de 50 textes qui ont été
adoptés au cours de cette première année
donc ça veut dire prenons les états
assemblées
essentiels les deux essentiels c'est le
budget et la loi sur la retraite c'est
deux ans de vie et de retraite pardon
volée aux Français sur le budget par
exemple nous avions une majorité de
députés pour avoir 12 milliards sur la
rénovation énergétique du logement
retoqué 3 milliards pour le
développement du train voyez là aussi
majorité de députés qui votent pour ça
retoqué par le 49-3 sur les retraites la
totalité des syndicats de salariés dit
nous ne voulons pas de cette réforme des
retraites nous proposons de choses nous
nous avons déposé il est vrai des
milliers d'amendements qui permettaient
aussi de dessiner un autre projet qu'est
ce qui a été 20 000 amendements pour
l'ensemble de l'année absolument rien
actuellement il y a et Priscille moi
nous sommes nous examinons le même texte
un projet de loi sur entre guillemets le
partage de la valeur il n'y a absolument
rien qui puisse augmenter les salaires
donc il y a un accord de tous les
syndicats
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut complémenter
d'ailleurs en prenant des propositions
des syndicats de salariés parce qu'il y
a un vrai problème c'est historique à
une baisse de 3% des salaires alors
qu'est-ce que l'on propose le début
beaucoup de choses pour le faire mais
qu'est-ce que retient la minorité
présidentielle rien et c'est bien ça le
problème de la façon de gouverner de ce
gouvernement on va retrouver à présent
Philippe Balard qui est député
rassemblement national de l'Oise il est
aux côtés de Marion Becker on va voir si
la stratégie du rassemblement national
cette fameuse stratégie de la cravate a
fonctionné depuis un an oui Brigitte
tout d'abord Philippe Balard une petite
question comment vous définiriez en un
mot cette année parlementaire
pas riche dense et puis peut-être une
note un peu plus personnelle en une
chance inouïe de siéger moi chaque fois
que je rentre dans l'hémicycle j’éprouve
toujours quelque chose et puis
apparemment j'ai Facebook métier de
journaliste alors je savais que c'était
danse mais là depuis un an en ménage pas
notre open je suis pas en train de vous
dire qu'on travaille trop on pourrait
peut-être aménagé le travail pour être
un peu plus productif mais on est au
service des Français et fier d'être ici
présent alors cette année le groupe
adopté ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
stratégie de la cravate ou de la
normalisation ça y est c'est assumé
c'est une stratégie qui a porté ses
fruits ou pas pour ce groupe ah bah
écoutez on regarde les sondages
évidemment on écoute aussi ce que nous
disent nos électeurs dans nos
circonscriptions oui je crois que c'est
une stratégie qui a été extrêmement
payante si vous regardez le sondage
Ifop publié dans le JDD dimanche dernier
on s'aperçoit qu'on est on est gagnant
sur sur tous les plans donc oui c'est
une stratégie gagnante alors on a
évidemment un regret nous on vote nous
Marine Le Pen nous a dit vous ne
regardez qu'une chose quel est quand
vous votez quel est des Français quel
est l'intérêt de la France donc si un
texte émane de la majorité
présidentielle on peut le voter je pense
aller à l'optimi par exemple au pouvoir
d'achat le compte n'est pas très loin de
là mais bon ça va quand même dans la
bonne direction on vote et on vote aussi
des textes qui viennent de la gauche qui
viennent de la nupes par contre c'est
par ici propre aucun de vos textes n'a
été voté juste tout juste quelques
amendements
c'est un regret c'est l'objectif pour
l'année prochaine comment passer ce
plafond de verre je crois que ça c'est
un reliquat de des vieilles années de la
politique mais les Français ne sont pas
dupes encore une fois quand on a des
études d'opinion ils nous donnent raison
donc bon ils peuvent continuer ce petit
jeu là mais je crois que les prochaines
échéances électorales nous donneront
raison et on aura plus besoin des votes
de la majorité actuelle qui est
minoritaire entre parenthèses ou de la
nups Merci à vous merci Philippe
premier groupe d'opposition ici dans
cette dans cette hémicycle est-ce que
vous diriez que depuis un an le
rassemblement national c'est normalisé
il s'est notabilisé depuis ces 12
derniers mois avec l'action qu'il a eu
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée alors
l'action que le rassemblement national a
eu dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je la cherche encore et
j'espère en jour en entendre quelque
chose puisque effectivement j'entends
monsieur Balard représentant du RN
parler en dehors de l'hémicycle mais on
les entend pas du tout dans le mycle
soyons très clair est-ce que j'ai me
plaindre du fait qu'on ne les entend pas
et qu'ils n'exige pas non en revanche
demandons-nous pourquoi ils opèrent
cette stratégie du silence et de la
cravate parce que de façon très claire
nous avons Marine Le Pen qui est la
leader du rassemblement national qui a
beau détesté farouchement les éoliennes
mais qui en imitent scrupuleusement le
mode dont fonctionnement dès que le
sondage dès que le vent du sondage de
l'opinion commence à souffler elle
change elle change de phrase elle change
de verbale elle change de mesure qu'elle
veut porter mais ils ont très clair
quand on gratte un peu on se rend compte
très vite que le rassemblement national
reste le rassemblement national reflux
identitaire relent sur des points de
voter quelques amendements en commun je
n'ai pas voté de d'amendements en commun
je n'ai pas voté d'amendement commun
avec le rassemblement qui ont été
adoptés du rassemblement national je
vous le dis de façon très claire je
continuerai à me lever dans l'hémicycle
en commission pour dénoncer ce qu'est le
rassemblement national et je dois le
dire ici de façon très claire nous
l'avons fait nous l'avons fait notamment
avec certains collègues de d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts avec certains
collègues du Parti socialiste avec
certains collègues du des républicains
et nous continuerons à le faire nous
pouvons continuer c'est pour ça que
j'insiste nous pouvons continuer à
débattre du fond mais avec cette ligne
rouge cette ligne rouge de rappeler que
le rassemblement national reste
farouchement le Front national Aurélie
trouvée vous avez adopté des stratégies
totalement opposées avec le
rassemblement national est-ce que
finalement celle du RN elle est pas
gagnante par rapport à vous quand on
regarde dans les sondages on a
l'impression que finalement le
rassemblement national monte plus que la
France insoumise plus que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'abord c'est faux parce que
quand vous regardez les sondages la nuit
passée devant dans tous les sondages sur
les élections quand elle est unie
d'accord par exemple pour les prochaines
élections européennes les sondages
montrent que la nuit pêche est devant à
la mais vous n'avez pas d'accord commun
pour partir justement à cette élection
le rassemblement national quand elle est
unie donc ça c'est une première chose
ensuite j'ai envie de dire le
rassemblement national quel que soit peu
importe la cravate ça reste un parti
avec des idées et qui ont un fond
raciste et xénophobe d'ailleurs et bien
quand le collègue de Fournas en vient à
dire retourne en Afrique à mon collègue
Carlos bilongo et bien il exprime
finalement ce qui est le fond du
rassemblement national
s'exprimer à propos du bateau le chêne
viking qui devait aborder un côté sur
les côtes françaises il s'adresse il
parlait du bateau alors c'est
la sanction la plus haute qui soit pour
cela et surtout je voudrais revenir à se
rassemblement national qui est un parti
je le rappelle qui vient du Front
national lui-même fondé par des SS il
faut se rappeler quand même l'origine de
ce parti mais c'est aussi et c'est très
intéressant je l'ai vu tout au long de
l'année un parti qui vote la plupart en
fait des propositions de la minorité
présidentielle par exemple dès lors que
je le vois en commission à faire écho à
faire économique dès lors qu'il s'agit
de favoriser par exemple les grands
propriétaires qui s'agit d'augmenter les
loyers de trois et demi pour cent dès
lors qui s'agit de combattre la hausse
du SMIC puisque nous avons proposé la
hausse du SMIC le rassemblement national
a voté contre donc vous voyez il y a
aussi quand même un fond de libéralisme
économique en faveur des riches et des
grands propriétaires
que c'est un fond du rassemblement
national qu'il partage en fait avec la
minorité présidentielle ce qui fait ce
qui fait que sur toutes ces lois là en
fait le rassemblement national vote avec
le parti d'Emmanuel Macron alors on va
voir à présent comment les républicains
ont vécu cette première année avec
Virginie dubymuller qui est député elle
est républicains de Haute-Savoie qui est
à votre micro Marion Becker les LR qui
ont parfois eu du mal à trouver leur
ligne effectivement Brigitte alors
Virginie du bimmunère tout d'abord un
petit mot pour décrire cette année
parlementaire votre année parlementaire
au sein du groupe la républicains alors
une année parlementaire très dense qui
nous a finalement obligé à être très
présent à l'assemblée nationale on l'a
vu sur certains textes assez joué à
quelques voix et finalement on s'est
rendu compte et bien que le Parlement
avait regagné en visibilité et en
légitimité puisque la majorité
finalement il lui manque une quarantaine
de voix sur chaque texte et ça les a
obligés à composer avec l'ensemble des
députés à travailler en amont et
finalement c'est assez positif pour
notre système de démocratie
parlementaire alors justement Virginie
du bimmunère le groupe les républicains
a parfois été un allié du gouvernement
parfois cela a été plus compliqué quelle
est l'avenir de ce groupe les
républicains de ce positionnement on
s'interroge beaucoup autour de cette
question d'alliance ou non avec la
majorité alors sur cette question de
positionnement nous ne sommes pas tous
d'accord effectivement sur la ligne à
choisir en revanche nous sommes
pragmatique et sur les sujets qui vont
dans le bon sens nous avons travaillé en
bon intelligence avec le gouvernement
sur le la question du nucléaire sur la
LPM pour et bien faire des propositions
et permettre des avancées donc lorsque
celle-ci sont prises en considération et
que les textes vont dans le bon sens et
bien moi je n'ai pas d'état d'âme à
voter des textes qui sont portés par le
gouvernement surtout lorsque ceux-ci
finalement se rapproche des positions
que nous avons toujours portées sur la
question du nucléaire par exemple nous
avons toujours été cohérents en faveur
et bien d'une souveraineté d'une
indépendance sur le nucléaire on voit
qu'au niveau du gouvernement il y a eu
des revirements entre la campagne de
2017 et celle de 2022 et que finalement
le barycentre d'Emmanuel Macron s'est
déplacé vers la droite donc c'est plutôt
une bonne chose qui montre que les
positions que nous portons avec
cohérence depuis un certain nombre
d'années sont les bonnes vous
continuerez donc sur cette voie pas de
coalition ou ce qu'on appelle d'accord
de gouvernement alors cela nécessite
déjà une volonté de la part du
gouvernement et du groupe Renaissance et
puis après il faudrait qu'il y ait un
contrat finalement de gouvernement avec
des choses très claires pour ma part je
pense que ça pourrait être une chose
assez utile pour le pays surtout en ces
temps troublé après il faudra qu'il y
ait une majorité au sein même de notre
groupe et pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément la position majoritaire qui se
dégage mais en tout cas on voit que
certains ont évolué là-dessus merci à
vous merci Virginie du bimmler pour ce
regard sur cette année
on voit que vous avez conclu beaucoup
plus d'accord avec la droite qu'avec la
gauche Virginie du bimmler la loi sur le
nucléaire la loi de programmation
militaire il y a eu aussi la le pouvoir
d'achat est-ce qu'il faut y voir un
tournant dans cette année un tournant
politique de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
non je pense et encore une fois ma
collègue du bubulaire le rappelle de
façon très simple avec transparence et
pragmatique d'ailleurs je salue ses
propos parce que j'aurais pu peut-être
tenir quasiment les mêmes soyons très
clair on a effectivement pu avancer sur
des textes voter des textes grâce à
certains LR mais aussi grâce à certains
de gauche PS ELV notamment sur les
énergies renouvelables ou sur les
violences faites aux femmes moi ce que
je tiens à dire ici et ce qui je le
rappelle juste mais 64% des textes qui
ont été votés cette première année le
sont avec les voix des républicains
encore une fois encore une fois je le
dis de façon très claire nous sommes la
majorité certes relatives et ça nous
oblige à avancer texte par texte suzué
par sujet mais il y a bien qu'une seule
majorité c'est la nôtre ensuite chacun
de sa responsabilité de sa cohérence
politique et c'est vrai que au sein des
LR et bien il y a pu avoir de temps en
temps au sein de cette même famille des
écarts idéologiques et attention parce
qu'à force des car idéologiques on
arrive à un claquage politique et ce
claquage politique il est dangereux il
est dangereux aussi pour la cohérence
que nous devons tous avoir en tant que
famille politique plus que jamais
aujourd'hui à l'heure où on sent que la
parole politique est remise en cause
peut-être pointer du doigt sur le fait
qu'elle serait un peu instable nous
devons rappeler que nous avons des
cohérences politiques sur laquelle sur
la base desquelles nous avons été élus
et donc moi ce que j'invite aujourd'hui
à faire aussi bien les LR mais une
partie d'épaisse une partie d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts une partie de l'yote
c'est de laisser les égos de côté et de
rentrer dans l'hémicycle avec les idéaux
qu'ils ont défendu Richard Ferrand a
appelé à l'unité nationale ce week-end
cette unité nationale n'est pas à
opposée avec la pluralité politique au
sein de l'hémicycle au contraire au
contraire arrêtons de voir des coups de
force partout et je le dis peut-être
aussi en une femme on a tendance à
considérer que la politique est en sport
de combat bien non aujourd'hui dans une
pluralité politique dans cette vitalité
qui est la nôtre et dans cette dose de
proportionnelle que nous avons à
l'Assemblée plus que jamais le sujet des
bras de fer doit être remplacé par une
politique des mains tendues alors
l'unité nationale pas vraiment de votre
côté à la France insoumise vous n'avez
voté aucun projet de loi sur cette année
qui vient de s'écouler pour vous tout
compromis ce serait égal à une
compromission en fait vous voyez le
problème c'est de ramener des
différences de point de vue et on a des
vraies différences de point de vue à une
question d'ego en fait il y a des idéaux
différents il y a des idées différentes
il y a une gauche il y a une droite et
il y a une extrême droite et entre la
gauche et la droite ce n'est pas pareil
et c'est ce qui fait que la nupaisse ne
vote pas comme la droite comme le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron et comme bien souvent
les républiques donc vous revendiquez
des convictions politiques bien sûr
justifier le non vote de ces projets de
loi en fait Emmanuel Macron il y a 6 ans
est arrivé en disant même je de faire du
en même temps il n'y a plus de gauche et
de droite mais justement je pense que ça
c'est la mort de la politique parce que
nous avons des idées différentes par
exemple nous nous voulons augmenter les
salaires nous voulons faire en sorte que
la tendance qu'il y a depuis 10 ans
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a de plus en plus
de valeur qui va vers les actionnaires
et de moins en moins qui va vers les
salaires et ça c'est en train de
s'accentuer avec l'inflation nous
voulons faire en sorte par exemple que
cela ça s'arrête et que enfin nous
puissions réaugmenter fortement les
salaires et les faire rattraper tous
leurs retard parce que vous savez que
nous avons des records de dividendes et
qu'à côté de ça il y a une baisse des
salaires réels l'année dernière ça par
exemple c'est un point de vue tout à
fait différent de ce que porte le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron et la droite et même
l'extrême droite donc vous voyez et bien
ça nous y tenons et vous vous battez
vous vous battrez certainement dans le
prochain budget pour bien porter vos
idées
elle est moindre majorité qu'on aura
trouvé une année vient de s'écouler dans
ce dans ce quinquennat et au terme de
cette année et bien une question se pose
pourra-t-on tenir 4 ans comme ça
Stéphanie desperres vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes dans la majorité comment
on envisage les prochains mois et bien
Brigitte l'exécuter l'exécutive pardon
ne sait jamais sur quel pied danser ici
à l'Assemblée tente de convaincre texte
par texte mais c'est un certitude pèse
sur les députés Renaissance beaucoup ne
voient pas comment cette stratégie peut
encore tenir 4 ans alors hormis horizon
et le modem leur meilleur allié ici ce
sont les républicains qui ont voté 64%
des textes discutés cette année alors
l'idée d'une retour pardon à une
coalidité d'une coalition avec les
républicains avec la droite et de plus
en plus évoquer ici notamment parce
qu'on parle d'un remaniement dans les
prochaines semaines alors au sein de
renaissance il y a deux groupes ceux qui
poussent en pour cette idée ce sont
souvent des anciens députés les
républicains ou des proches
d'anciens proches et puis il y a l'aile
gauche de la majorité qui surtout n'en
veut pas il y a une grande réunion
demain au parti renaissance pour évoquer
cette idée mais Aurore Bergé la
présidente des députés Renaissance mais
en garde il ne faudrait pas que cela
vienne fragiliser notre majorité alors
en attendant les députés a continué à
travailler ils vont continuer à jusqu'à
fin juillet il n'y a pas de texte majeur
il y a simplement un texte sur
l'industrie verte mais le prochain grand
texte pour le grand présidentiel ce sera
à la rentrée en novembre le projet de
loi immigration Elisabeth borne a
prévenu ses troupes ce matin la rentrée
ne sera pas de tout repos
est-ce qu'on peut continuer quatre ans
comme ça à la recherche de compromis en
faisant ce que Gérard Larcher appelle du
cabotage vous allez on va pas se faire
cette ce petit dialogue tous les ans
effectivement blague à part on a eu
cette discussion avec vos confrères
aussi et vous-même je pense l'année
dernière à cette même place en se disant
est-ce que vous allez tenir l'été est-ce
que vous allez tenir à l'année avec
cette majorité relative et force et de
constater c'est ce qu'on disait en début
d'émission que oui nous avons nous avons
réussi à faire voter des textes donc
nous allons continuer mais il y a eu
mais il y a eu la réforme des retraites
qui a quand même été profondément
vivante ici dans les cellules vous avez
est-ce qu'il y aura pas un avant un
après ce que vous allez pouvoir
continuer comme ça vous avez totalement
raison il y a eu la réforme des
retraites et encore une fois je le dis
de façon très claire il s'agit pas de
tourner la page mais de contraintes
continuer à écrire l'histoire et nous
avons continué à écrire l'histoire parce
que ce qui serait impossible
impardonnable de notre part en tant que
parlementaire de tout serait de rentrer
dans l'immobilisme serait de rentrer
dans une action politique bloquée
bloquée non pas pour nous mais pour les
Français nous avons avancé sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants et nous devons
continuer à le faire sur les énergies
renouvelables sur le nucléaire il s'agit
de notre souveraineté énergétique quand
même mais également sur des sujets du
quotidien qui monopolisent aussi
beaucoup les conversations notamment les
parents sur les influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux nous avons aussi avancé
sur des sujets d'ambition sur la loi de
programmation militaire et nous avons
avancé hier soir en commission en
finissant à minuit et demi sur le sujet
du dialogue social et l'accord retrouver
sur le partage de la valeur
d'intéressement la participation
exactement donc vous allez continuer
comme ça nous non seulement nous allons
continuer mais nous n'avons pas le choix
nous devons le faire non pas pour nous
mais pour celles et ceux qui nous ont
fait confiance vous tendez la main à la
France insoumise Aurélie trouvée est à
votre à votre gauche moi je veux bien
alors j'ai rien contre les trouver
encore une fois moi je combats pas les
gens je débats des idées et sur les
idées de la France insoumise moi j'ai un
petit un petit nombre d'inquiétude j'ai
un petit nombre d'inquiétude sur les
violences faites aux femmes moi je ne
comprends pas comment le lundi on peut
condamner les violences faites aux
femmes et le mardi applaudir dès demain
acclamer un homme reconnu coupable de
violences faites parler
non plus la cette facilité qu'ils ont à
toujours en permanence pointée du doigt
les forces de l'ordre et cette énergie
qu'il dépense à venir en permanence
venir dénigrer l'institution dans
laquelle eux-mêmes ont voulu siéger qui
est l'Assemblée nationale donc ça veut
dire des compromis mais avec qui alors
mais pardon mais la France insoumise
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique française aujourd'hui et je
suis désolé de le dire aussi de façon
très tranquille
la nuque c'est une coalition électorale
mais absolument pas une famille
politique en leur siège il y a aussi
bien des gens qui sont pour le nucléaire
que ceux qui sont contre il y en a qui
sont pour la viande et d'autres qui sont
contre le barbec écoutez moi je veux
dire encore une fois il y a peut-être
encore des choses et des choses à
définir au sein de la nupes peut-être
que le cas des élections européennes
sera le moment de mettre cela encore à
deux clarifier peut-être les mais de
clarifier les je voudrais vous laisser
répondre Aurélie trouver parce qu'on
comprend bien que ça va continuer
allez-y Ferrer comme ça avec des
compromis text par Tex pas forcément
avec la France insoumise parce que vos
idées sont un peu éloignées visiblement
est-ce que vous vous êtes prêts à porter
le fer 4 ans comme cela d'abord je ne
suis pas d'accord pour dire qu'il y a
des compromis il y a aujourd'hui un
gouvernement qui impose les lois les
plus importantes par 49-3 qui empêche et
cette historique ça n'a jamais eu lieu
depuis 1958 le budget est par nature
de niche parlementaires et je parle de
celle de du groupe centriste liotte de
niche parlementaire qui était retoquée
par le biais d'un article de la
Constitution je vais vous dire la
minorité présidentielle a fait les fonds
de tiroirs de la Constitution pour
empêcher que nous puissions voter sur la
réforme des retraites tout simplement
parce que nous avions une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale la minorité
présidentielle le savait très bien c'est
pour ça que vous l'avez empêché vous
avez mis un 49-3 sinon vous ne l'auriez
pas fait voilà donc sinon 49-3 si vous
saviez que vous avez la majorité sinon
pourquoi pourquoi avoir empêché de
trouver vous savez que le pendant du
49-3 c'est la motion de censure je vous
invite l'institutionnel et vous l'avez
utilisé l'émotion de sens mais il n'y a
pas de majorité alternative mais est-ce
qu'il y a une majorité alternative
l'émotion de censure sont ce qu'il nous
reste aujourd'hui en tant que député
pour affirmer notre rejet notre refus de
cette façon de gouverner de ce
gouvernement non seulement nous avons
des différences importantes d'idées mais
aussi nous ne sommes pas d'accord nous
nous opposons fermement au fait que
cette démocratie parlementaire soit à ce
point-là affaibli par ce gouvernement et
d'ailleurs je le dirai je dirais que
vous disiez il y a un avant et un après
de la réforme des retraites oui d'abord
la question parce qu'il y a
effectivement une loi qui passe contre
la ville de la totalité des syndicats de
salariés et contre la vie de 9
travailleurs sur 10 les sondages sont
formels semaine après semaine 9
travailleurs sur 10 qui refusent que
vous n'avez pas réuni de majorité sur
votre motion de censure alors contre
cette réforme des retrait que nous
voulions c'est la motion de censure
c'est est-ce qu'on fait confiance ou pas
ce gouvernement nous nous voulions un
vote sur la réforme des retraites nous
savons nous savons que nous l'aurions
remporté mais ça a été empêché d'abord
par un 49-3 et ensuite en empêchant la
niche parlementaire de l'OTE et ben oui
vous avez empêché par l'article 40 de la
Constitution nous nous voulions voter
nous voulions absolument voter vous
l'avez empêché en première lecture le
mensonge et en deuxième lecture mais
enfin par un 49-3 mais en commission on
a voté je vous parle de la séance parce
qu'en commission ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'ils ont l'hémicycle il y a pas
eu interchanger les députés LR qui les
arrangés pour pour que ça puisse refaire
ce débat mais en tout cas mais c'est
important parce que aujourd'hui nous
voyons évidemment des droits de
l'opposition qui sont affaiblis
maintenant je vais finir sur ce qui va y
avoir bon on voit bien que le
gouvernement est en train d'amplifier sa
politique de cas soci une politique très
libérale sur le plan économique et une
politique qui refuse d'augmenter les
salaires par la loi c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer donc nous nous y
opposons fermement nous allons continuer
tout notre travail parlementaire
d'amendement de propositions loi en
espérant une chose c'est que on puisse
avoir une petite marge de manœuvre pour
faire passer des propositions de loi
pour faire passer des amendements
contrairement à tout ce qui s'est passé
cette année et je finirai sur la nuit
Pesse la nupesse aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale elle est unie sur
la plupart des votes elle prépare
ensemble des propositions de loi elle se
bat ensemble elle a mené toute la
mobilisation et vous allez continuer à
faire juste nous étions dans la rue
toutes les semaines je peux vous dire
que j'étais
effectivement vous avez manifesté juste
un tout petit mot mais une réponse très
rapide prise catéveno la première
ministre que vous avez reçu en réunion
de groupe intergroupe de toute la
majorité ce matin a dit la rentrée ne
sera pas de tout repos ça veut dire
qu'il faut s'attendre à de nouveaux 49-3
non c'est à dire qu'il faut s'attendre à
ce que les débats continuent à être
houleux et dans ce comme ils le sont
quand même au sein de la majorité avec
le projet de loi immigration et vous a
appelé à l'unité d'ailleurs sur
l'immigration nous sommes unis et c'est
bien cette unité de la majorité
présidentielle avec Renaissance le
modèle et horizon qui fait que nous
avons aussi réussi à tenir une cohérence
politique sur le fond mais aussi des
modalités d'action sur la forme la ligne
même que nous a demandé de tenir le
président de la République et c'est bien
cela qu'auteur d'une devons saluer et
d'ailleurs j'en profite de façon très
rapide en conclusion de celluler le
travail des présidents bergers marchand
jelly et Mattei qui sont unis et qui
nous permettent d'avancer aujourd'hui et
un dernier mot peut-être parce qu'on en
parle très rarement mais c'est tous les
collaborateurs les collaborateurs
parlementaires les collaborateurs de
groupe les codes rapator de commission
qui sont là nuit et jour aussi pour
faire en sorte que ces débats houleux et
ben continuez à exister et continuer à
exister le mieux du monde
aussi de la tête merci pour eux en tout
cas et merci à vous d'avoir accepté de
venir débattre dans cette émission sur
cette première année ici à l'Assemblée
au cours de cette année il y a aussi un
petit groupe hétéroclite qui a fait
entendre sa voix sur la réforme des
retraites résolument opposés au décalage
de l'âge de départ il a tenté de faire
voter une proposition de loi pour
l'abroger son président Bertrand pencher
président donc du groupe lyaute est aux
côtés de Marion Becker avec vous Marion
et oui Brigitte bonjour Bertrand pencher
alors c'est votre année
année de la consécration pour vous et ce
petit groupe de 21 en tout cas le groupe
liotte a été au coeur de beaucoup de
débats le groupe diode s'est révélé à
travers la qualité de ses membres et le
groupe liotte a été remarqué par
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens comme un
groupe parlementaire finalement très
proche de très proche des territoires et
très à l'écoute c'est d'ailleurs l'ADN
de notre groupe puisque nos groupons des
anciens parlementaires socialistes
jusqu'au
parlementaire centriste droite en
passant par des régionalistes et des
députés ultramarins et on se rend compte
que comme par enchantement parce qu'on
sait s'écouter et bien nos décisions
sont prises à l'unanimité je pense que
ça plaît bien au à nos concitoyens on
est un peu aussi le David contre le
Goliath on a failli renverser le
gouvernement à neuf voix près notre
fantasme c'est pas de de bouleverser
tous les équilibres mais notre fantasme
notre souhait c'est de faire réussir le
pays et il y a malheureusement encore
très loin de la les lèvres alors vous
êtes devenus le point central un petit
peu le point d'équilibre entre les
oppositions le groupe par lequel il faut
passer finalement pour pour négocier
c'est votre objectif pour l'année
prochaine de venir un contournable dans
les négociations
notre objectif serait de vraiment avoir
un gouvernement et un président de la
République à l'écoute on voit bien que
cette année a été une année très très
erratique vraiment dans vraiment
d'Annecy une année qui a provoqué la
profonde division de ce pays et on voit
bien que les réformes de fond pour notre
pays sont loin d'être mises en place on
est le pays des plus riches du monde
avec des impôts les plus élevés nos
services publics rien ne fonctionne
comment rien ne fonctionne dans notre
pays et ce groupe qui incarne également
un choc d'écoute et de décentralisation
pensent que en ramenant les décisions
plus proches de nos concitoyens faisant
en sorte qu'on supprime toutes les
couches bien on sera beaucoup plus
efficace et comment est beaucoup plus
juste c'est vraiment un des objectifs
qu'on caresse à condition cependant
d'avoir un gouvernement et un président
de la République à la recherche du
compromis du compromis pour un programme
de réforme pour notre pays il faut
vraiment que ça soit la mission du
prochain Président de la République je
vous dis pas que les jours de
d'Élisabeth borne soient vraiment
comptés et il faut vraiment qui est ce
mandat de façon à faire en sorte que les
priorités partagées par les groupes
républicains et notre en particulier
soit mise en place et qu'on arrête de
nous imposer des projets de loi venus
d'en haut en discutant le moins possible
en passant en force et on voit que tout
ça contribue à vraiment détériorer la
démocratie dans notre pays et bien
entendu bertrand-ponchard vous allez
continu
er à pendu ici pour avoir de nouvelles
priorités merci à vous merci
si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à 20 moins de 20 minutes
des questions au gouvernement qui vont
avoir lieu dans l'enceinte de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale et
que vous pourrez suivre donc en direct
et en intégralité à partir de 15 heures
sur la Chaîne Parlementaire vous le
voyez derrière moi la revue des troupes
vient d'avoir lieu et la garde
républicaine est en place elle est prête
pour accueillir la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et jouera
d'ailleurs du tambour à 15h juste pour
l'arrivée de Yaël Braun Pivet alors avec
moi dans cette émission vous retrouverez
toujours Stéphanie Despierres et Marion
Becker qui se trouve salle des quatre
colonnes vous retrouverez également
Valérie Brochard qui est dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale et
puis nous vous ferons vivre l'arrivée de
la première ministre et des membres du
gouvernement juste avant 15h ce sera
cours d'honneur l'entrée principale du
palais Bourbon Valérie vous êtes donc
dans les tribunes de l'hémicycle quel
est le sujet principal de ces questions
au Gouvernement cet après-midi
et bien Brigitte elle a une dans
l'hémicycle cette semaine la
manifestation qui s'est déroulée samedi
dernier dans la vallée de la Maurienne
les députés vont interroger dans
quelques instants les ministres qui ont
eux aussi suivi les événements entre
3000 et 4000 opposants à la future ligne
ferroviaire Lyon-Turin c'était donné
rendez-vous sur place lancé il y a 30
ans ce projet de ligne à grande vitesse
fait toujours débat aujourd'hui les
députés de la majorité comptent revenir
sur ce rassemblement pourtant interdit
par le préfet de savoir et sur les bancs
de la France insoumise c'est le chantier
en lui-même qui pose question le forage
à travers le massif alpin pour creuser
les 57,5 km de tunnels représenterait
une véritable menace écologique sécurité
intérieure environnement nous verrons
dans quelques instants comment les
différents membres du gouverneur du
gouvernement aborderons ce dossier et
Valérie quels seront les autres thèmes
qui seront abordés cet après-midi
et bien le groupe les groupes
Renaissance horizon et écologistes
reviendront sur les mesures dévoilées
par la première ministre concernant les
ruralités au pluriel une quarantaine de
dispositions proposées par le
gouvernement pour répondre aux enjeux
spécifiques des campagnes un élu modem
interrogera également le gouvernement
sur le fond d'urgence pour reloger les
habitants touchés par le tremblement de
terre en Charente-Maritime enfin les
élus du groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine questionneront le bilan de
la politique menée dans les outre-mer
merci Valérie Brochard pour l'ensemble
de ces questions on revient d'ailleurs
tout de suite sur une des questions qui
sera posée par le député démocrate
Nicolas turquois elle concerne le
rapport annuel du corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites il sera
rendu officiellement jeudi mais voilà on
en connaît déjà la teneur et c'est assez
explosif puisque il ne prévoit pas
véritablement de retour à l'équilibre
dans trois scénarios sur 4 en tout cas
pas avant 2045 il est au micro et bien
de Stéphanie Despierres tout de suite
Nicolas turquois calez-vous demander au
gouvernement à propos de ce rapport du
corps
hier j'ai découvert par des articles de
presse les premières premiers éléments
de ce nouveau rapport quête publié jeudi
je suis tombé de ma chaise j'ai vu ce
matin des éléments plus concrets ce
rapport du corps l'année dernière avec
les mêmes éléments indiqués que les
déficits étaient de l'ordre du trait
donc ne nécessitait pas une réforme mais
là ils disent que la réforme est pas
suffisante en un an de temps un tel
changement moi me pose question et donc
je vais lui demander qu'il est l'opinion
du gouvernement sur sur le corps quelle
méthode on peut mettre en place pour
avoir des éléments plus objectifs et
plus rationnels si l'on regarde ce que
dit le corps là ça veut dire que la
réforme n'a quasiment servi à rien
puis ce régime des retraites sera dans
le rouge dès l'année prochaine
que les déficits seraient encore plus
grands mais que qui ne serait pas
suffisant donc c'est c'est vraiment un
élément de trouble pour pour l'opinion
c'est l'élément sur lequel c'est fondé
le précédent rapport c'est fondé les
oppositions pour attaquer fortement
l'action du gouvernement et là il adopte
une position presque inverse je suis
scandalisé merci beaucoup
merci Stéphanie des pierres Élodie
Jacquet la forge
vous pouvez garantir vous la réforme des
retraites que vous avez votées elles
elles permettra de retrouver l'équilibre
en 2030 parce que c'est ce que vous nous
avez promis alors moi je vous avoue que
je suis un peu victime
le précédent rapport du corps nous
disait c'est pas nécessaire il y a pas
besoin de faire de réformes finalement
on fait une réforme et on nous dit si
j'ai bien compris qu'elle va pas assez
loin donc ça pose question effectivement
sur les le compte rendu du rapport du
corps et est-ce qu'on doit aller plus
loin on voit que par rapport
aux critères qu'on a utilisé pour faire
la réforme on voit que la situation
économique c'est dégradé que l'inflation
a continué et même qu'elle a augmenté
même si elle est maintenant stabilisée
en tout cas on l'espère pour pour l'été
on voit finalement que c'est des
critères extérieurs qui ont changé donc
ça veut dire que ça change la donne
finalement pour votre réforme c'est pour
ça qu'on avait prévu vous le savez au
groupe démocrate une clause de revoyure
en 2027 pour voir si effectivement les
mesures qu'on mettait en notamment pour
l'emploi des seniors qui a vous savez on
a un taux d'emploi des seigneurs qui est
extrêmement faible donc si on augmentant
aussi ce taux d'emploi des seniors on
arrive effectivement à équilibrer le
système ce qui est ce qu'on recherche
alors vous Pierre Cordier vous étiez
contre cette réforme des retraites
pourquoi parce que vous pensiez
effectivement qu'elle permettait pas de
retrouver l'équilibre comme le dit le
corps écoutez les éléments qui ont été
transmis par le corps aujourd'hui par le
de même moins vous le venez de le dire
j'étais opposé à la réforme des
retraites parce que je savais que cette
réforme n'aboutirait pas aux résultats
escomptés on avait déjà une hypothèse de
plein emploi en 2027 avec 4,5% de
chômage et une inflation maîtrisée ce
qui n'est absolument pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc qu'est-ce qu'on va nous
dire demain il faut aller jusqu'à 67 ans
jusqu'à 70 ans puis après jusqu'à 72 ans
pourquoi parce que tout simplement on
n'a pas eu le temps dans ces 50 jours
imposés par le gouvernement d'examiner
toutes les hypothèses et on entend là à
votre antenne un député quand même de la
majorité du mode qui nous dit qu'il est
tombé de sa chaise on entendait ces
éléments évoqués par le corps donc moi
je le rejoins tout à fait moi c'est même
pas de ma chaise que je suis tombé c'est
carrément du placard parce qu'on l'a
voté c'est très fort mais elle est
décrets d'application qui ne sont même
pas encore sortis et on nous dit
clairement que cette réforme est un
échec alors
sur les les éléments
deux Allemands la diminution du déficit
tel qu'il était prévu parce qu'on passe
au 06 à 0,2 presque 3 fois donc on voit
qu'effectivement le déficit il est
réduit est-ce qu'il est suffisamment
réduit non et je crois que c'est pour ça
que c'est nécessaire d'avoir cette
clause de religion jusqu'à 70 ans alors
jusqu'à 72 ans
il y a plusieurs critères qui peuvent
être prises en cours ils n'ont pas été
par le gouvernement en tout cas nous on
avait on avait chez les réponses
c'est vrai un débat il y a des gens chez
nous qui étaient favorables à la réforme
d'autres qui étaient contre et je pense
que ceux qui étaient favorables la
réforme et en tous les cas avec les
hypothèses alléchantes qui étaient
évoquées par le gouvernement et bien on
voit aujourd'hui que tous s'écroule
alors vous allez vous allez nous dire
que heureusement qu'on a fait cette
réforme parce que ce serait encore pire
les questions
d'une retraite à 65 ans oui et pour vous
dire que en 2003 vous avez toujours
défendu une retraite à 65 ans je
voudrais quand même je voudrais quand
même la présidentielle de la République
il y a deux ans et demi disait qu'il me
toucherait pas au système de réforme tel
était auparavant donc je pense que là
dessus tout le monde a pu évoluer dans
ses convictions à ce sujet moi j'ai
toujours été de droite et je l'assume
c'est pas pour autant que je suis les
yeux fermés ce que pouvait dire Valérie
Pécresse ou François Fillon alors on va
parler à présent d'une autre question au
gouvernement alors que vous entendez la
sonnerie retentir ça fait beaucoup de
bruit ici dans cette salle des pas
perdus on va parler de cette ligne de
TGV Lyon-Turin qui suscite beaucoup de
débats de manifestations des
affrontements qui ont eu lieu ce weekend
entre écologie et force de l'ordre et
notamment les soulèvements de la terre
qui s'opposent à cette ligne TGV qui
serait selon elle un désastre écologique
alors le député la France insoumise de
la Savoie Jean-François Coulomme
souhaite interroger le Gouvernement sur
ce sujet et on le retrouve tout de suite
au micro de Marion Becker et oui
Brigitte alors Jean-François Coulomme
vous étiez présent samedi dernier à la
manifestation contre ce Lyon-Turin
pourquoi interpeller le gouvernement
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
et bien parce que voyez-vous face à
l'urgence climatique face à l'urgence
écologique nous avons assisté ce
week-end en Maurienne à une
manifestation des soulèvement de la
terre mais pas que il y avait également
de nombreuses organisations et
mouvements politiques dont Europe
Écologie Les Verts la France insoumise
qui ont décidé en quelque sorte de
manifester leur opposition à un projet
inutile ruineux et considère et qui
dispose au jour où l'on se parle d'une
alternative qui pourrait pour quelques
dizaines de millions d'euros
supplémentaires faire tout à fait
l'office qui consiste à faire un report
modal des marchandises qui sont
aujourd'hui transportés par la route sur
le rail et nous avons donc au cours de
cette séquence eu une organisation
parfaitement Pacifique je le dis sur un
terrain privé en dehors du périmètre
interdit par la préfecture de Savoie qui
était celui proche des installations
industrielles on le comprend mais cette
manifestation donc non l'interdie je le
rappelle encore se dérouler dans un une
ambiance parfaitement au bon enfant avec
des ateliers des changes des débats des
Colocs en même temps sur le terrain où
on avait la le rassemblement le plus
important et il y a eu cette volonté de
faire un cortège de défiler sur les
routes adjacentes on est en pleine
campagne je vous le rappelle et pour des
raisons bien évidentes quand on imagine
les forces de l'ordre ont tenté
d'empêcher le cheminement de ce défilé
de ce cortège et ça s'est évidemment
encore une fois mal terminé puisque nous
avons eu des violences policières qui se
sont abattues sans discernement avec
grenade etc sur les manifestants ou sur
le cortège de tête vous allez dénoncer
la répression de ces manifestations
c'est bien ça bien évidemment parce que
vous voyez on est là dans un continuum
en quelque sorte de répression policière
et pénale de criminalisation du
mouvement social tel qu'on l'a observé
pour la loi contre les enfin la loi
retraite et nous avons aujourd'hui bien
évidemment une répression féroce des
mouvements écologistes et des militants
écologistes aujourd'hui au moment où
l'on se parle il y a des rafles qui se
déroulent en France
pour propre à de l'arbitraire pur auprès
des militants des soulèvements de la
terre que ce ministre d'ailleurs et ce
président veulent dissoudre pour des
raisons qui ne sont absolument pas
justifiées puisque ce n'est pas une
association c'est un groupement et on
écoutera justement la réponse du
ministre dans l'hémicycle tout à l'heure
Merci à VOUS
Élodie Jacquier Laforge est-ce que c'est
une nécessité cette ligne de TGV
Lyon-Turin si nécessité elle est
attendue et moi je pense à tous les
habitants notamment des vallées qui sont
concernés par le trafic auto Elodie
Jacquet laforgia Marine Le Pen qui vient
d'arriver salle des quatre colonnes qui
va s'exprimer sur le quai de Bordeaux ou
une septuelle génère a été violentée par
un SDF avec sa petite fille on l'écoute
de cette agression à Bordeaux parce que
elles sont en quelque sorte
symboliques de la délinquance que
subissent nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
gratuite
imprévisible de plus en plus violente
plus un seul quartier plus une seule vie
plus un seul village n'est préservé du
développement de cette insécurité et le
sentiment que l'on a c'est que le
gouvernement ne prend pas la mesure de
l'explosion de cette insécurité je ne
suis pas du tout sur d'ailleurs je suis
même sur du contraire que dans le projet
de loi concernant la justice il y a des
réponses à porter à l'explosion de cette
insécurité c'est vrai que
ceci a fait beaucoup réagir et c'est
parfaitement naturel car il est
parfaitement naturel que l'aggravation
continue de l'insécurité
touche nos compatriotes et suscite chez
eux et chez nous par définition de
l'indignation
s'exprimer sur ce cas à Bordeaux donc
une seatuagénaire violentée par un sans
domicile fixe avec sa petite fille
projetée à terre et le SDF a été
interpellé très rapidement par par la
police et on sait que la famille s'est
dit indigné par la récupération
politique et le dit Jacquier la forge
est-ce que vous y voyez une forme de
récupération politique
bah écoutez déjà il faut voir
effectivement les choses telles qu'elles
se sont passées et que la à la fois la
police face au travail la justice
derrière c'est vrai qu'on a tendance je
trouve à réagir avec beaucoup d'émotion
ce qui est compréhensible parce que ce
qui s'est passé est inadmissible mais je
pense qu'il faut laisser le temps aussi
à l'examen précis des choses toute forme
de violence est inacceptable et c'est
vrai que sur des enfants et sur des
personnes âgées c'est d'autant plus
rassemblement national c'est finalement
qu'il y a une montée de la violence dans
ce pays et que voilà un cas comme
celui-là
jamais peut-être sur le devant de la
scène cette violence que vous ne voulez
pas voir peut-être que à leur
gouvernement on ne prend pas assez
suffisamment au sérieux la violence elle
existe elle existe vous le savez aussi à
l'encontre des élus on a vu des maires
qui étaient aussi concernés par des
violences physiques chez eux donc la
violence elle existe elle est prise en
compte mais si vous voulez c'est au-delà
de l'émotion une nécessité de la prendre
en charge par les forces de l'ordre et
par la justice on ne peut pas de
soi-même se rendre justiciable ce serait
la fin de l'état de droit Pierre Cordier
même question est-ce qu'il y a de la
récupération politique ou pas sachant
qu'il y aura pas de question au
gouvernement de la part du rassemblement
national sur cette affaire de Bordeaux
et est-ce que vous trouvez que le
gouvernement devrait en faire plus en
matière de sécurité comme nos
compatriotes choqué par ces images et il
est normal aujourd'hui que les hommes
politiques de ce pays fassent des
commentaires mais également agissent et
c'est vrai que les statistiques depuis
un certain nombre d'années dans ce pays
ne sont pas bonnes ça avait déjà débuté
à coucou François Hollande était
président de la République ça se
poursuit aujourd'hui on attend des
réponses concrètes alors bien entendu la
police doit faire son travail bien
entendu la justice doit faire son
travail il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui donc compatriotes veulent
des réponses parce qu'ils sont énervés
et agacés et triste finalement de voir
dans quel état est notre pays donc on
attend les réponses du ministre de
l'intérieur elle se font quand même un
petit peu attendre depuis un certain
nombre d'années par Emmanuel Macron et
ses gouvernements successifs il est
temps d'agir il y en a marre et personne
n'a le monopole de la sécurité dans ces
pays dans ce pays moi je suis de droite
je l'assume et on attend des réponses
claires de la part de ce gouvernement
alors il y aura pas effectivement de
réponse de Gérald Darmanin sur cette
question précise de Bordeaux puisque
aucune question ne sera posée ni par le
rassemblement national ni par d'autres
groupes d'ailleurs cet après-midi merci
à tous les deux d'être venu débattre sur
le plateau de questions d'actualité on
va retrouver tout de suite Marion Becker
pour le menu des questions au
Gouvernement Marion quelles sont les
principales questions qu'on retrouvera
cet après-midi et bien Brigitte à la Une
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle la question
du lion Turin cet axe ferroviaire ce
projet ferroviaire lancé il y a 30 ans
contesté par les écologistes et la
France insoumise la majorité et elle
dénonce les manifestations de violences
qui ont lieu ce week-end la différentes
questions au gouvernement de ces
différents groupes vont donc être posés
cet après-midi et puis également
différentes questions sur le plan rural
utéruralité pluriel lancé par Emmanuel
par Elisabeth borne là aussi différents
groupes de la majorité et de
l'opposition vont interpeller le
gouvernement enfin un élu modem
interrogera le gouvernement sur le
relogement des habitants après le
tremblement de terre de
Charente-Maritime car vous le savez des
habitants ont dû être évacués suite à
des fissures dans leur maison et puis
enfin une question du groupe GDR sur la
politique en outre-mer menée par le
gouvernement
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de thèmes
d'ailleurs qui seront donc abordés cet
après-midi leur séance de questions au
gouvernement qui va démarrer dans moins
d'une minute maintenant Stéphanie
despierges je peux vous dire il y a
beaucoup d'ambiance ici ça le dépasse du
parce qu'on attend la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale quel est l'état
des lieux chez vous il y a eu beaucoup
de monde de beaucoup de journalistes
dans cette salle des quatre colonnes il
y a quelques minutes Marine Le Pen a
improvisé un point presse pour répondre
aux questions des journalistes et pour
dénoncer l'agression de cette grand-mère
et de cette petite fille hier à Bordeaux
et puis là vous l'entendez les tambours
résonne alors on l'a dit il n'y aura pas
de question d'actualité à proprement
parler sur ce sujet mais Marine Le Pen a
voulu s'emparer de cette agression même
si la famille dénonce déjà une
récupération politique et dés hier soir
les républicains eux aussi avaient
beaucoup publié de messages sur les
réseaux sociaux pour dénoncer cette
agression
merci Stéphanie Despierre et vous le
voyez sur ces images la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale arrive de l'hôtel
de lacet et du fond de cette salle des
pas perdue qu'elle traverse sous les
tambours de la garde républicaine
[Musique]
qui va désormais rejoindre l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale pour présider
cette séance de questions au
Gouvernement
une séance où on va revenir sur la ligne
de TGV Lyon-Turin et ses affrontements
écologistes et force de l'ordre ce
weekend on parlera aussi du rapport du
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui dit que la réforme n'est
pas suffisante pour ramener le régime à
l'équilibre et puis une question aussi
sur le tremblement de terre qui a eu
lieu en Charente-Maritime très bonne
séance à tous on se retrouve juste après